He asks is there a extraversion
and IQ correlation?
Yes, we have new data on this.
This is very interesting,
extraversion and IQ are slightly negatively
correlated, based on a massive meta analysis
that hasn't been published yet.
I'd love it if the authors would
go ahead and publish it.
It was a master's thesis.
But, yes, they found very
slight negative correlations,
I downloaded the thesis because it's
relevant to a broader interest of mine,
of what traits are going to get promoted
under a regime of artificial selection (i.e.
designer babies), where people get to
choose what their offspring are like.
So basically, what you're saying is
that if people choose their offspring,
they will choose very weakly stupidity.
Oh, women overwhelmingly want
highly extroverted offspring.
They do not want highly intelligent offspring.
So in terms of the genetic correlation between
those traits, that will make
it negative very quickly.
Is it a genetic correlation?
Yes, that's a standing prediction I have.
Why?
Because
one of the reasons for the correlation, is recent
patterns of directional selection, a very intense
directional selection, which has been operating
on these populations for the last 200 years.
We need to tease apart the variance components,
and the problem with the correlation between IQ
and extraversion, is it's rather small.
So you need a very, very large sample,
to really get at the shared
genetic variance among components,
which are largely independent of one another.
And you can do power calculations to work out
exactly how many twins you
would need to throw at this.
But there might be a simpler way of doing it.
I actually have two data sets, some very good
ones, in which there are polygenic scores for IQ,
and also phenotypic data on some of the big five.
So if extraversion is in there, you
could do a really interesting study,
to see if you can use the polygenic scores for IQ,
to mediate any, phenotypic associations between IQ
and extraversion, that we find in those data sets.
Then we don't need the twins.
And we can also increase the
power to detect the effect, as the sample size
is like 10,000 each for both of the studies.
I was wondering about some research, I found,
which said that extraversion is part of the GFP,
the general factor of personality,
which for people that aren't familiar,
this is a measure of social effectiveness (high
GFP people expend more effort essentially).
However, part of the GFP is extraversion.
But I understand that extraversion is weakly
associated with short term sexual relationships,
which has an inverse relationship with the GFP.
Well, they would be related
only insofar as extraversion
is related to venturesomeness and dominance.
So this is one of Kevin McDonald's ideas from way
back, when he was still a personality psychologist
studying the evolution of personality.
He had this idea that the big five in humans,
should be made to look more like the big five
in chimps, because there's a different
big five in chimpanzees and gorillas.
Instead of an extraversion
and an agreeableness factor,
they have a dominance factor, which
captures dominance and venturesomeness.
And they have a warmth and affiliative
factor, instead of an agreeableness factor.
So what Kevin argued is,
we should tweak the factor structures
by imposing these oblamin rotations,
in order to recover these more
evolutionarily informed big five.
So you still have the big five,
it's just you forced certain
things to become dominance, and you forced
certain things to become agreeableness,
and in doing so, you've made them
into slightly different things,
which align a bit more with
what we notice in primates.
So it would be interesting to see what happens
to the GFP, when you do those rotations.
Does this flip the sign of the association
between extraversion and the GFP?
My longstanding prediction is, yes, it should do.
It should actually make the association
with the GFP negative,
because now instead of
getting all the gregariousness in the extraversion
factor, you're now forcing it into agreeableness
as part of this affiliative factor.
So all the gregariousness that would
ordinarily rate you as high extraversion, because
you'd like going out and interacting with people,
but you don't necessarily like
dominating them, trying to take
control. You're not highly directive, to
use John Jay Ray's old term for his scale,
from the 1970s, on authoritarian behavior,
which he called the directiveness measure.
The best measure of authoritarian responding we
have, by the way, is Ray's directiveness scale.
So in other words, you're getting
a directiveness scale, and you're
putting that directiveness scale possibly
in negative conjunction with the GFP.
It'd be very interesting to see what
that does to the factor structure.